[Music]
up next on book notes frederick kemp
senior european correspondent for the
wall street journal joins us to discuss
his book divorcing the dictator
america's bungled affair with noriega
it's a look at the inner workings of u.s
foreign policy in panama and america's
relationship with general manuel noriega
mr kemp is the former chief diplomatic
correspondent for the journal and
reported about the region from 1988
through early 1990
[Music]
frederick camp author of divorcing the
dictator america's bungled affair with
noriega
and uh in your epilogue you have one
sentence and i want you to talk a little
bit about america not noriega is its own
worst enemy what do you mean
well and the another sentence in the
epilogue says that foreign policy isn't
made it just happens and i think that's
what i'm saying is that the u.s started
this relationship without really
thinking what the consequences were
we never knew long term what we wanted
from noriega when we started the
relationship in 1960 he was a cadet
peruvian military academy castro had
just taken over in cuba and what we
wanted were small pieces of information
about instructors at the military
academy about fellow students who might
have leftists or communist tendencies
noriega however
knew all along what he wanted out of the
relationship he wanted a career he
wanted the prestige that came with being
america's man and he also wanted the
training counter intelligence training
intelligence training demolition
training all the various sorts of
training that we gave him without which
he never would have been able to rise
through the ranks as successfully as he
did so i think that's what i'm trying to
say is to a large extent the united
states created the problem it later had
to correct through an invasion of uh 25
000 men have you ever met uh general
noriega
i met him at the rio otto base uh in
october actually november of 1988 and i
think you remember this is the base
where stealth bombers hit in the
december invasion
and i went up to him i i introduced
myself to him and it was very
interesting because he wasn't much like
a dictator he seemed more shy and
withdrawn the only thing that really
showed that he was a leader was he had
this penetrating stare a real
intelligence agent stare
but i shook his hand and it was really a
damp and limp handshake not the sort of
handshake you expect from a dictator and
i told him i was doing a book
and he promised
to give me several long interviews for
the book which he never delivered on
that said he did make available to me a
lot of his high school friends peruvian
military academy friends political
allies and that was quite helpful
because through them i got into
noriega's circle and i think that's one
of the things that sets this book apart
is not only do i have a lot about the
opposition in the history but i also got
inside of noriega's circle and found out
a little bit more about what made him
tick
there's a note
in
back in the back and you have each
chapter
delineated and you have special notes
that better explain what's
behind the chapter
and
i want to ask you about this gathering
the details of noriega's early life
presented one of the more difficult
reporting projects for this book
involving interviews with family members
and former childhood friends who
primarily spoke anonymously because of
fears of retribution from general
noriega who endeavored to keep
information about his early life secret
those willing to speak on the record are
quoted this account includes many new
details that haven't before been made
public right right
the uh noriega is not proud of his
childhood now omar torrillos the
dictator that preceded noriega
was very proud of his humble upbringing
was very proud that his parents were
school teachers in a small town in
panama but noriega's mother uh
i was told she died when he was age five
and she was a domestic servant for his
father who never accepted him until
noriega was age 11 or 12
and he didn't grow up as the poorest
person in panama but he was poor
he was adopted by a godmother and the
godmother actually was a very kind
godmother
and so he didn't have he had a mean
streets upbringing obviously but he had
a godmother who loved him who dressed
him very well who groomed him very
neatly
i met one of his school friends a man
named hector manfredo who was his best
friend when noriega was age seven and
you see these are the types of stories
that really
i thought enriched my understanding of
noriega to talk to someone when he who
was his best friend when he was age
seven i said to hector manfredo well
what drew you together and he said well
it was a shared introversion neither one
of us liked to talk much and we could
sit silently in the back of the room i
said well did you play games what did
you do was he athletic and he said no
even then he wasn't a games player he
was a serious man and he just liked to
watch other people so already at age
seven you could see shades of the
intelligence agent who would come
and i think of noriega more in terms of
being an intelligence agent than a
dictator because that's what he did
longest and that's what he did best he
was never very good as a dictator he
didn't have the charisma he didn't have
an ideology most dictators have an
ideology
it was the first time you ever went to
panama
i went to panama already in 1985 1986
covering stories on the contras the
sandinistas going to the southern
command there and visiting sources
and that's when i first got interested
because of course at that time
you had a stolen election
that the u.s endorsed even knowing it
was stolen
george schultz traveled to the
inauguration of the president that was
elected at that time actually a very
good and honest man nicholas ardito
barletta
but in his briefing book going to the
inauguration
was a cable that outlined how the
election was stolen
and
and i went at that time and i became
intrigued already with the country
but the book and this hard work on the
book started in the fall of 1988 you
speak spanish i speak some spanish
enough to get by here and there but in
panama
curiously enough
it's not
it's not the same
must that it is in other latin american
countries
the history of panama is so tied into
the united states
that it probably is the only latin
american country in that entire region
where one can actually do a good job of
reporting
without a fluent knowledge of spanish
in the acknowledgements to begin the
book you thank norm perlstein
the managing editor of the wall street
journal for his support but then you say
i am deeply grateful for his willingness
to humor my curious passion
when did you get a curious passion for
panama well some people say it's a
perverse obsession
but i i i i think
when i first got fascinated was i was
diplomatic correspondent of the wall
street journal and as diplomatic
correspondent you look
to learn how american foreign policy is
made or not made and for me
i was attracted to the panama book for
two reasons first of all i thought this
was an excellent model through which one
could study how bureaucracies work and
really don't work and how american
foreign policy is made the fact that
there are many forces at work and it's
not national will but it's bureaucratic
momentum
it's individual ambitions it's uh it's
compromise and this is the way it's made
and i thought the panama story was the a
very good model to show that and not
only that you had this fascinating
character of noriega so i thought the
book was a good way of telling a serious
foreign policy story but almost in a
novelistic way to bring in a general
reader that normally wouldn't read a
foreign policy book when was this book
originally supposed to be published
i had finished the book in december and
we were going to go through a uh a long
period of uh editing galleys all of this
business and the book would have come
out in june
and i heard word uh from a source of
mind i'd gone off to celebrate finishing
the book in aspen and a source of mine
called me and aspen and said you better
end your ski holiday and get yourself to
panama
and this was a very good source and so i
prepared to move myself to panama
uh and was this this was i actually
arrived in panama two days after the
invasion coming up the road from costa
rica driving up from costa rica in a
school bus
we rented a school bus because we
figured it was less likely the school
bus would be fired upon going to panama
city
i and another journalist
and
i used that opportunity to write an
extra two chapters the first chapter in
the last chapter of the book so
everything was finished in december and
we added a first chapter in the last
chapter i was very lucky because one of
my
better friends during this period of
reporting was the nuncio i spent a great
deal of time talking to him
and when noriega ended up in the
nunciatora it was a bit of a godsend for
my own book because i was able to get a
very good feel for what life was like
for noriega in the nunciature and
there's a chapter written about that
what what is annuncio i'm sorry the
papal nuncio is the vatican's ambassador
to panama
and when noriega went on the run he was
on the run for four days five days after
the invasion four days after the
invasion
uh it turned out that that was where he
sought refuge in the end
i have a copy of a book that you no
doubt have seen
this is john dinges book our man in
panama the only reason i show it on this
program is to ask you whether or not
this has helped or hurt you
as john dingus comes out with a book on
panama at the same time and when you
read a lot of the reviews the two of you
are reviewed together right i think it
helps and it hurts it's i think it's a
good book it's it doesn't cover as broad
of a territory as mine does and because
of that to have two serious books on a
mat and on a historical moment i think
is a good thing for society now for my
own book obviously i wish that my book
were the only one that people had had to
buy
but
but that being said it also focuses more
interest in the subject more broadly it
brings more people into the bookstore
asking
for a book about noriega
and so i think that obviously in overall
sales perhaps i'm a little bit hurt but
i don't think that society is hurt
through it uh since since i think both
books are credible and and and decent
books did you know while you were
writing your book that john dingus of
national public radio was doing his yes
i did you crossed paths
uh we crossed paths here and there but
john
worked very much from um from public
record
and in the and also
the
the the history that i have in my book
he goes into as well but in the last two
years he hasn't been much in panama so i
was i did not run across him there he
does not
he does not go so much into the current
events of the last two years as i do
one of the criticisms you read in the
some of the reviews is that your book um
well one of the things that we talked
about briefly is that they
may have tried to put it out too fast
because of the invasion and you're
saying basically that wasn't the case
they just moved the press
run up
yeah that no that isn't the case
isn't the case at all in fact i'm quite
happy that
the last two chapters which should have
been
hastily written chapters chapters that
really didn't tell you much more than
were in
the newspapers i was able to get a hold
of some intelligence cables uh one of
which a debriefing of uh of a man who
had traveled with noriega in his last
four days that gave new detail of where
noriega went how he got there the fact
that he was in hyundai south korean sub
compact running from one crony's house
to another one of the cronies houses
where he stayed he stayed in the locker
room of this sort of lavish health club
of a millionaire's home i mean this was
not a dictator this was not shay guavara
going to the jungles to fight a
guerrilla battle this was a uh this was
a man who was running a large
corporation called the panamanian
defense forces which controlled so many
different aspects of panamanian society
and in the end he really didn't have the
stuff
to lead a fight for his position he was
more interested in saving his own skin
and so i think that these chapters are
some of the strongest chapters in the
book because i was able to come up with
this intelligence material what do you
say that critics should say you you
focus too much on
the oddities of
general noriega his bisexuality and his
pension for prostitutes and his interest
in
mistresses and all that
there's a lot in the book and whenever
you come out with a great deal of new
information
people who don't have that information
are going to criticize it or question it
that being said i think anyone who reads
the book closely will see that i've been
quite careful about what i've put in the
book i was about to write a chapter
called rumors because i have
piles of paper and notes of things that
i couldn't put in the book because i
couldn't corroborate it for instance one
of the one of the sources that i spent a
great deal of time with jose blandon he
was one of noriega's closest associates
right-hand man of blandon glenn a
right-hand man of noriega blandon spent
no time with any other book author i
spent hours and hours with him
he is a source that one has to treat
gingerly one he's a very very clever man
but he also has a political agenda so
you corroborate everything you get from
a man like that for instance he said
that george bush instructed noriega to
call fidel castro to warn him in advance
of the grenada invasion
that fact isn't in my book because i
couldn't corroborate it he also
testified before a grand jury
that he
that he participated in a mediation of a
dispute between the medellin drug cartel
and noriega noriega had raided a drug
laboratory that the median cartel had
set up in panama in 1984
against an agreement and an alleged
agreement that noriega had struck with
the median cartel they paid a great deal
of money for protection of that
laboratory
landon said that he mediated this
dispute that's a key point in the
indictments i have that story in some
length in some detail in the book and
the reason for it is i was able to
corroborate it and for a book like that
this i think
the hardest job was not coming up with
the information
it was coming up with the corroboration
and hours were spent that the reader
won't even notice
trying to make sure that i didn't
overstep the balance when i write that
the man is bisexual believe me i have
talked to people who were intimately
involved
with noriega in one way or another and i
was able to confirm that to my
satisfaction how did his personal habits
affect the way he lived
i think noriega was a man who liked
control i think that's what motivated
him he wasn't motivated by ideology and
he was motivated power to to a certain
extent but i think control was the key
and he and and one sees that in
everything he did his sexual
relationships i think there was a matter
of control the way he ran the panamanian
defense forces as a centrally run
organization much more centrally
controlled than it was under dictator
omar trios and then the panamanian
defense forces took over control through
law number 20 of the constitution
immigration customs
and they controlled a number of other
things ranging from horse racing and the
lottery to airports ports
he really
turned
the pdf the military into a diversified
corporation over which he was the
chairman of the board how did you do
how many times you go to panama i went
to panama on
four or five separate occasions probably
spent a total of six or seven months in
panama
just one line i wanted to ask you about
in panama
queenie
out to murano
took me on voyages that placed her in
more danger than she wanted
you're acknowledging people what did you
mean by who is she well queenie
altamirano was a
researcher who worked for me and an
interpreter who worked for me as well in
in panama and she was very very plugged
into some very interesting circles in
panama
and we
the the trip that i'm referring to i
couldn't
say it at that time but i think i can
now we went into the cherokee province
and we met with gorillas who had been
tortured or who had been locked up by
noriega in the past
and we had to meet secretly with them in
the mountains at
pre-set locations sometimes they would
show up sometimes they wouldn't show up
some
one of them was actually trembling as he
talked to me and he spent more time
pleading with me not to use his name and
then at the end of the meeting he even
pleaded with me not to use the
information
and to see that these guerrillas
who were actually locked up by noriega
20 years ago more than 20 years ago were
still this nervous of the man
taught me a lot about the man
uh and uh and i think that without the
help of of queenie i would not have got
to a lot of these individuals eva loser
who saved me from embarrassment
because i am not a lifelong panama
expert i relied on certain experts to
read my
read my manuscript and make sure i was
not doing anything that was historically
inaccurate or factually inaccurate
ava lozer
certainly isn't responsible for what's
in the book but she's an expert on
panama at csis the center for strategic
and international studies in washington
and she spent many long evenings reading
every page of my manuscript at the end
making sure that
or to the best of her ability making
sure that i didn't make any historical
or factual mistakes that jumped out at
her two reporters provided invaluable
assistance james dorsey m scott malone
who are they whenever you write a book i
actually should have listed probably 20
or 30 reporters there
but these two spent the most time with
me working on it
scott malone is i think one of the
better investigative reporters in this
city and he's done some excellent work
for frontline pbs
james dorsey who's worked in the past
for the christian science monitor and
for upi now working for the washington
times knows the region very well and is
very very well plugged in into military
other circles down there
and at times in a crisis situation
it pays off for a journalist to work
with other reporters because you share
information you share insights and also
their safety in numbers and it's much
better to go out into a dangerous
situation with two people
james dorsey and i for instance rented
that school bus together and we came
across the costa rican border and drove
up
from the costa rican border border to
panama just three days after the
invasion you have any problem as you're
going about your job writing a book like
this that your friends and other
reporters know what you know
and do they have to
not publish it in their own publications
how do you how do you deal with
information you come up come on together
well i was quite liberal with
printing information i would find out
along the way for the in the wall street
journal obviously there's so much
information the book that you don't get
it all into a newspaper but by and large
i didn't find that was a problem even if
you had a news break in a newspaper you
can't flesh it out in the detail you
can't tell the story in the way that you
can in a book so very often when i would
do reporting together with one or the
other reporter
i didn't find it was a conflict of
interest at all some other names that
our viewers will recognize because
they've been right where you are doing
call-in shows david ignatius's deft
touch and instincts helped me shape the
theme in writing
why david ignatius well david ignatius
is an old friend of mine he was the
middle east correspondent for the wall
street journal in london when i was the
east european correspondent and his
backup in the middle east in london
and it always helps to have a very very
s
very trained eye as you know david is
had been the editor of the outlook
section in washington post
uh a trained eye look over your
manuscript every writer needs a good
editor and david is one of the best the
other one i list there alan murray
was was equally helpful and also has a
has an incredibly keen eye
for what's missing or what ought to be
in
and again i turn to these people because
in doing a book of this size you really
need the help that you can get from the
cleverest and the smartest editors that
you have and they very often will point
you in a direction or suggest
a means of telling a story that you
might not have fallen upon yourself
be good at chapter 17 because it seemed
to be a good place to talk about uh
it's
way into the middle of the book and
there's so much that we're not going to
cover here but it seems to be a good
place to talk about
our own government and what happens
inside but first i want to ask you and
the name comes up
first page of this chapter who
michael harrari is
michael hirari
is a very interesting character he
was
a head of i think it was called special
operations in the mossad
and after the in israel right in israel
he's an israeli mossad agent and was
very and was on his way up to the top of
the organization
and then he led the teams after
the um uh the massacre at the munich
olympics of massacre with the killing of
of israeli athletes of the munich
olympics
he led the team that was to hunt down
the palestinian terrorists unfortunately
in norway he killed a
he killed a moroccan waiter instead of a
palestinian terrorist it was a great
embarrassment to the mossad and to the
israeli government
he was able to get away from that but it
harmed his career he was sent off to
mexico
to be station chief for the mossad
somewhere in this period he got to know
the dictator omar torrios
omotorios's wife was jewish
at one point michael hirari intervened
because uh
trios's wife's father was not very happy
with the fact that she was married to
this panamanian dictator who was of
course not jewish and michael herrari
did some brokering and did some and and
it was a personal favorite to trios and
torrios was very touched apparently this
started
a close relationship
noriega was the intelligence chief under
this dictator michael hirari being a
mossad man of course worked very closely
with him and this relationship
again this is one of the things in the
book where i don't write nearly as much
as i was told simply because i couldn't
corroborate a lot of it
but one does know that harare was very
close to noriega
that noriega trusted few panamanians and
that he did trust harari he trusted him
with certain domestic political missions
carrying messages to certain politicians
and apparently he trusts them trusted
him also in matters regarding the the
regarding arms trade
although i wasn't able to confirm this
with documents
the panamanian government is said to
have provided end-user certificates for
the israelis when they want to provide
arms to certain parts of the world where
they can't get the end user certificates
what's that what's an end user
certificate and user certificates if you
want to if you want to buy weapons
from a government
there are certain governments that
aren't allowed to buy weapons during an
embargo for instance iran during the war
with iraq was not allowed to buy weapons
from many different countries in the
world
so panama would provide an end-user
certificate in other words panama would
be buying the weapons but they would
never go to panama they would go to iran
didn't i read that they went from the
soviet union to iran
through panama yo well the weapons
themselves of course would never have
gone to panama but the end user
certificate would read panama they may
go through another means but you had an
israeli working for a panamanian
brokering arms from the soviets to go to
iran through panama exactly exactly and
it didn't stop there the uh the embassy
panama's embassy in vienna
was a passport factory for intelligence
agencies that wanted to operate in
eastern europe the israelis of course
the israeli passport wasn't was
a problem you don't get you didn't get
into parts of eastern europe with that
sort of passport or the soviet union
but a panamanian passport was accepted
everywhere and so the jewish panamanian
ambassador in vienna was a very useful
conduit for passports for israeli agents
according to intelligence sources that i
had for the book we're talking about
this book called divorcing the dictator
and our guest is fred kemp are you still
on leave from the wall street journal
i've come back to the wall street
journal as a matter of fact
i am
after this book is out and i've i've
made my rounds i'll be taking over as
the wall street journal's
first berlin bureau chief covering
east-west relations and when will you go
to berlin uh june 1st will be the
official opening date of the bureau but
i'll travel off there next month already
michael hirari where is he now
my karari is back in israel
and
the wall street journal
ran a story a
very interesting story that outlined how
he got there
and
it certainly suggests that someone
helped him out of the country and that
there was a conscious decision made not
to arrest him
someone meaning
i one can only guess that it was either
israeli agents on the ground who helped
him get out or american agents on the
ground who helped him get out but but he
certainly did get help in getting out
let me ask a question for the many
viewers that have called about this over
the last couple months michael hirari an
israeli former mossad
agent
was he there in panama on behalf of the
israeli government that's a very good
question and i don't think i have a
satisfactory answer all i know is mossad
agents when they retire do go into their
own private businesses harare obviously
did have private businesses in panama
um in fact he was known as mr 60 for the
large commissions he would take from
israeli businessmen who would try to set
up operations in panama and these were
legitimate businesses that being said
i'm told by intelligence experts that
these mossad agents are on call when the
israeli government needs their their uh
their services they will be called upon
and obviously
my karari has built up a number of
contacts and important
intelligence contacts over the years and
those don't evaporate just because
you've decided officially to retire
chapter 17 again u.s policy follies
who was colonel herrara hassan well
colonel
herrera hassan
was uh
the chief of security for omar torrillos
the dictator omar torrios
he is of the opinion that noriega was
involved in one way or another with the
suspicious helicopter excuse me a plane
crash in 1981 that took the life
of torios two years later after some
maneuvering noriega was able to take
over power
he
he was because of his closeness to this
dictator noriega pushed him off into
various embassies
at the time that the u.s turned against
noriega herrera hassan was the
ambassador
to
israel
interestingly enough though it was
really my kurari the mossad agent we
were talking about who was running the
embassy herrera hassan was there and
mike hirari was watching him
and so you see there are all sorts of
intrigues all over in this paid by home
uh he was the he was the honorary consul
to panama so the panamanian government
was paying my carrari as the honorary
consul living in jerusalem living in
jerusalem but also living in panama
going back and forth
um
herrera hassan expressed to me
frustration that
really it was very difficult for him to
act as ambassador because harrari was
really in charge of the operations there
when the state department wanted to get
something moving
against noriega they needed an exile
military leader what year was this this
was in 1986 excuse me in 1988
uh
the the indictments came in february
1988 and then late in february president
eric arturo del valle president of
panama tried to fire noriega tried to
push him into resignation instead
noriega got rid of him and he went into
the underground so this is where the
crisis really starts speeding up in
february of 1988. march of 1988 a state
department official bill walker flies
secretly to israel to meet with herrera
hassan and says
we want you to help us we want you to
fly to washington on a secret mission
and help us
get rid of noyega herrera hassan
said he would do so thinking that if
this man is coming all the way out to
israel to recruit me to this mission
then the entire u.s administration must
be behind it but he was wrong
even as the state department was coming
out to seek this
help from colonel herrera hassan
the pentagon was fighting what the state
department was trying to plan which was
some sort of exile military activity
that would lead to noiga's overthrow
probably through a coup
so herrera hassan by the time he lands
in washington the plan that he was
supposed to be the central figure in has
been defeated in interagency battles and
so he becomes the first victim
of american foreign policy battles
because he was left out to drive one
little fact i want to ask you about our
current u.n ambassador thomas pickering
was the ambassador from the united
states to israel
who approached
he made the colonel he made the initial
contact to see if
the colonel would be willing
to meet with the visiting state
department official how do you keep
track of all this
lots of papers lots of documents lots of
interviews and lots of double checking
with the sources
i had this whole story for instance in
this story i had this whole story from a
series of sources
um
and i took it to herrera hassan
and then i asked him to tell me his
story without telling him the details
that were in my story
and his story matched my story detail by
detail when you get two completely
different sources
uh corroborating the same story without
them knowing what you've learned from
the other then you're pretty confident
of your story at some point in this
chapter i remember you writing that
the colonel the ambassador from panama
to israel
approached from a u.s state department
uh man walker right flies to
israel
asks him to come to washington right
ambassador
from panama to israel flies to
washington and by the time he gets here
there's a line in here that says we
don't want him anymore who was that that
said they didn't want him anymore well
it wasn't so much they didn't want him
anymore the thing is this man was being
used
by the state department
as part of their game to push through
something in the bureaucracy so the
state department was at war with the
pentagon we weren't only at war with
noriega the state department was at war
with the pentagon the state department
was filled with dove excuse me the state
department were really the hawks in this
episode they wanted to militarily take
action
they were the ones that suggested some
sort of commando raid that would bring
noriega's kidnap and bring him to
justice in the united states okay the
pentagon were the dubs okay i was going
to read that line these events began a
bureaucratic war between a pacifist
pentagon and a militaristic
state department exactly but i want to
ask you the name name so that we know we
can back this was 1988 last year the
reagan administration
who are the
who are the militarists over in the
state department and who are the
pacifists in the pentagon uh the uh the
militarist at the state department would
have been eliot abrams but people
misunderstand they think that eliot
abrams shaped this entire policy eliot
abrams wouldn't have been able to do
this unless secretary of state george
schultz said yes please
i i approve of what you're doing
abrams believed that that reagan had
said we have to get rid of noriega and
he was frustrated that this goal had
been set but the pentagon was blocking
all resources or policies that would
actually lead to the fulfillment of the
goal
admiral crowe
the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff led the charge on the other side
now
you also see the difference in white
chairman the joint chiefs of staff
against an assistant secretary of state
who was not as powerful as the chairman
of the joint chiefs of staff and part of
the problem for eliot abrams in the
state department was george schultz was
traveling a lot during this time and so
at the interagency meetings he didn't
have the strong voice of the secretary
of state behind him admiral crowe
thought that this was a fool's mission
in fact at one meeting he said to the
president do you really want to risk the
lives of american soldiers from peoria
illinois
to unseat a dictator when the panamanian
people themselves aren't willing to risk
their lives to get rid of him
and that's a very strong argument how
did you by the way how did you know that
admiral kraut in a private meeting said
you don't want to risk people from
peoria illinois
to get this dictator out there i was
able to get notes from some of the
meetings
in other cases i had sources tell me
what was said and then i would take
that account of the meeting to the other
side in other words
to admiral kraus people or people close
enough to admiral crowe or people in the
pentagon who had been involved in
meetings one way or another
and i would check the account and they
would either say yes that's true no
that's not true
but that's the way i would play it were
you suggesting though that admiral
krauss said peoria illinois because
president reagan was originally from a
small town near there well i i then say
that he knew how to speak reagan's
language and then i point out
that uh reagan was from
tampico
tempico tempico illinois the um dixon
illinois yeah
in that area exactly in that in the
dixon illinois areas and uh
and i'm sure i'm not sure if crowl
picked the city for that reason but he
certainly picked the way of saying this
because he knew this was the way to
appeal to the present but there's
another very interesting point in this
and that is for president of the united
states to take military action when his
military officers are telling him it's
foolhardy is a very very difficult thing
to do because he trusts his military
advisors
why
because they are the ones who know the
cost they are the ones who know what's
logistically possible
and so to have
secretary shultz or eliot abrams say
these people aren't telling you the
truth
well or these people are exaggerating
the cost or the danger because
the pentagon was saying if we take this
action you're going to have hostage
taking
there are 40 to 50 000 americans living
in panama you would have massive hostage
taking they argued and a hostage-taking
situation probably scares the president
more than anything else you see how much
problem we're still having
with hostage taking
and i think the real
change obviously the many changes
between the reagan administration the
bush administration but the real change
in december of
1989 when the invasion took place was
the national security adviser colin
powell said to the president
yes i go along with this plan and we
actually have a workable plan that we
can carry out that i think will do the
trick when he became
chairman of george jesus under george
bush exactly when when uh colin powell
took over for uh admiral crowl as
chairman of the joint jesus death this
gets awfully complicated let's go let's
let's go back to 1988 because it's an
exercise and understand how our own
government operates internally
president reagan is sitting there
waiting for suggestions from his state
department and his pentagon right
admiral crowe who has a phd in political
science from stanford that's right
says
don't use military force to go in and
get this little dictator
elliot abrams is pushing for military
force to excise him from that country
and his harvard law degree and his
harvard law degree
so you have this battle of intellects uh
and very different men difference in age
a difference in age crowd has has had
led commands he was much more of a
down-to-earth speaker
i mean he would sometimes hide his
intellect
behind the sort of oshux exterior which
was very effective in interagency
battles
now the actual person who was versus
elliott abrams in the interagency
meetings wasn't crowl himself it was
vice admiral jonathan howe again a very
very effective infighter because he had
been in the political military bureau of
the state department and he had also
worked in the white house in the past
you describe him as humorless brilliant
calculating and arrogant exactly you
ever meet him uh i have
is
met
him
uh from what you saw when you met him
yes he's a very impressive character and
he knew how to go around the bureaucracy
he knew how the state department worked
he knew how the white house worked and
he knew how the pentagon worked and in
these interagency battles those are very
valuable skills in retrospect was elliot
abrams right would they have saved 25
men and
million billion dollars or whatever it
cost for the invasion if they had gone
in you know i didn't want to make a
point of who was right or wrong i wanted
to tell the story and leave it to the
reader to decide but i will make one
judgment and that is that ronald reagan
didn't intervene to settle this battle
he didn't he didn't come down and say
okay you both have these opposing views
let's now have a real policy which is
measured and well thought out
what grew out of this bureaucratic
paralysis
was a policy of not of most effect but
of least resistance and that policy of
least resistance was economic sanctions
and economic sanctions were imposed in
april of 1988 by ronald reagan not
because anyone thought this was the most
effective policy in fact the pentagon
didn't think it was a good policy state
department didn't think was a good
policy commerce and treasury certainly
didn't think it was a good policy but
the sanctions were decided upon because
they were the only that was the only
policy everyone could agree upon
let me read you a line just about adam
crowe before we leave that particular
part of this he was now authorized to
express his own opinions
and so unilaterally solve conflicts
among the chiefs of each of the services
this is a result of the 1986
law that was passed that very goldwater
among others was behind to change the
power structure at the pentagon uh crowd
had become the most powerful peacetime
military officer in american history
right
what's the
is there anything else you can say about
the upshot of that law and is that law
do you think a good thing
well i think the the law
was designed to give the chairman of the
joint chiefs
more power to express his opinion and
more power to speak his own mind
uh in the interagency battles that took
place therefore bringing him up closer
to the the power of other cabinet
members in these sorts of uh
these sorts of decisions
but i think
the real difference
certainly he was in a position where he
could speak for himself and speak his
own mind and put this through an
interagency meetings but also admiral
crowl himself was a very effective
man in that position and he was hand
picked by ronald reagan to take that job
during the reagan administration
so very often as we know james baker
james baker's power in this
administration comes from his close
relationship to george bush not because
he's secretary of state he's more
powerful as secretary of state because
of his close relationship and i think
that ronald reagan trusted admiral crowe
enough not to distrust him when he said
that military action would be too
dangerous and therefore i don't think we
should undertake it
what other lessons did you learn from
watching or going back and and getting
both sides of this story and were both
sides anxious to tell you what happened
i became more anxious once you once they
discovered how much
information breeds information and once
you have information from a meeting it's
easier to go to a participant of that
meeting who wouldn't talk to you before
and then he'll say no you've got this
wrong you've got that right okay let's
talk about it in more detail and so one
of the things one learns from writing a
book like this is that you revisit
sources and you go back to them time and
again the best your your better sources
and um and i think that
what i what i learned from this whole
episode
is that what drives american foreign
policy
is a very complex mixture of things it
isn't a neat process that you can draw
on a chalkboard but rather it's a
combination of bureaucratic momentum and
bureaucratic imperatives what the
pentagon wants what the state department
wants what the treasury wants
individual ambitions what eliot aber
rooms wants what admiral crowl wants
and also of uh of what's
on the table that day in may of 1989 you
may remember there was an election in
panama that was annulled thereafter the
vice presidential candidate in that
election billy ford appeared on time
magazine with a blood drenched shirt
suddenly panama was on everybody's mind
but a week later there was a massacre in
tiananmen square and not only does it
disappear from the television screens it
also disappears from the president's
agenda not disappears entirely but it
takes a lower priority and in washington
where you only have so many hours in a
day that affects how you pursue policy
davis was a political ambassador whose
first try at diplomacy came in paraguay
after president reagan's 1980 election
he came to panama in 1986 after his wife
had died in a plane crash and panama's
crisis cut his time of mourning short
thrusting him into the uh
uh on to the unforgiving stage who was
davis arthur davis was the ambassador to
panama during this crisis
and
and
a very kind-hearted man a man who cared
a great deal
about human rights and a man who
was very emotional
in his support for the opposition in
panama and in his
uh and in his opposition to general
moriega this is in the same chapter
where we're talking about government
structure here chapter 17. the embassy's
press section went to lengths to keep
their ambassador out of the public
limelight because of his inarticulate
shoot from the hip approach to sensitive
diplomatic matters it it it was i i took
some strain in getting my interviews
with ambassador davis
simply because the press section of the
embassy
ambassador davis is not a trained
diplomat he's not a person who talks in
diplomatic niceties
he's a supermarket developer from
colorado whose main
claim to the reagan administration was
the fact that he was a friend of joe
joseph and holly coors in colorado
and he was very effective at times as an
ambassador but because of the way he
would drive after things with emotion
but the diplomats around him were afraid
to let him too loose because he would
also say foolish things he wasn't
diplomatic enough he uh
he he wasn't
he wasn't an operator in the sense that
one might have needed
an operator now you have dean hinton as
ambassador to panama he's a much
different sort of ambassador here's a
man who has been ambassador of pakistan
helping to run the afghan war ambassador
costa rica and bastard el salvador this
is this is a diplomatic heavyweight
they've now put in panama i think part
of the reason they put this diplomatic
heavyweight in panama
is that arthur davis was considered not
a weighty enough figure for this time of
history in panama and he was the
ambassador from the united states to
panama in 1988 how important is that
ambassador in this mix
i think the the ambassador in the mix is
very important
partly because
of the southern command you have an odd
situation where the general of the
southern command fred werner and the
ambassador arthur davis
are two powerful
individuals in the same country
fred werner had admiral crowe's ear
when he said something wouldn't work in
panama
he would he was the head of
of 13 000 troops
he was a four-star general he was
listened to arthur davis did was not all
that close to either george schultz or
ronald reagan
he did not have the sort of ready access
or the punch in washington that a
general warner would have with admiral
krauer with the pentagon and so that
again weakened the state department
because ambassador davis couldn't throw
the weight around in washington that a
four-star general running the southern
command which was based in panama he
couldn't throw that kind of weight
one last thing on ambassador davis this
is continuation of where you say the
press
the embassy's press section went to
great lengths to keep
the ambassador out of the limelight
they were even more upset that he
couldn't control his daughter
and knew first lady susan his wife had
died in plane crash who had become one
of the opposition's most boisterous
backers she'd go to the front lawn of
the embassy residence to bang on pots
and pans and embassy personnel
complained that she often released
classified information to reporters in
an effort to promote the anti-noriega
cause
true i
it is true it wouldn't be there if it
weren't and i don't know i mean well
there's a lot
susan davis was
a woman who was very very emotionally
involved
in the opposition's cause very close to
the office who's the opposition at this
point oh the opposition at this point is
the civic crusade band of businessmen
who were against um
against noriega and who really started
the first strong demonstrations in june
of 1987 against noriega also
the del valliere family president devali
when he went to underground the del
valle family
lived with the davises in their
residence
gabrielle lewis the leader of the
political opposition
the panamanian political opposition here
he used to be the panamanian ambassador
to washington during the panama canal
treaties one of the most one of the
strongest forces in the opposition his
whole family lived with the davises in
panama when they had to hide from
noriega and whenever susan davis or
ambassador davis would come to
washington they would susan davis
particularly would would stay at the
gabriel lewis home here so the closeness
between the opposition and the embassy
was
the sort of which one sees very very
rarely because it's not considered
diplomatic when you're a diplomat you're
supposed to keep your ties open to all
sides and therefore you know what more
what was going on and i do think this
was one of the great weaknesses of the
embassy i think the embassy didn't know
enough what was going on in the ruling
party in the ruling circles or in
noriega's circle i think the embassy
shut itself
out of that partly because it had to
because of sanctions and because of
diplomatic cutoff but also partly
because it didn't try hard enough
through other means to maintain these
ties where is susan davis today
i'm not i'm not sure where's the
ambassador today the ambassador is uh i
think living in washington giving
speeches here and there he's still uh he
was working over the state department
as the ambassador sitting in the state
department up until the time that dean
hinton replaced him about a month or two
ago as you're going through the process
of gathering information for this book
and you're
writing chapters like this what's coming
across your mind about our
the way we do business
well i guess what i really want to do is
have a book that tells people how
foreign policy really is made the
academics consider these sorts of
factors as not sufficiently serious
to
or many academics don't consider them
sufficiently serious
and part of what i try to do with this
is give the academics the sort of
journalistic information that will make
their studies of foreign policy
better
and also i think the kissingers and the
brzezinski's of the world when they
write their memoirs
i th they they are of a stature of
individual where they can't really get
into the gossipy sort of things that i
get into
but these gossipy things shape policy
the fact that ambassador davis as an
ambassador doesn't have the weight the
general warner as head of the southern
command this shapes how policy turns out
and so i guess this was my aim in the
book is to make it lively enough to
bring the reader in but also through
this show them that american foreign
policy making
is
a messy and anecdotal and uh and really
quite a fascinating affair
another uh
sentence here i want to read
because our viewers know this man from
seeing him on the call-in shows here and
he's also written books
some of the most detailed and troubling
stories to the state department written
by washington post pentagon
correspondent george wilson long here's
what i want to ask you about long a
favorite reporter of the uniformed
military they like him they think he's
straight they think he's honest they
think he tells a good story
military sources are an interesting
bunch and i really like them and it's
because they're straight they what games
they they they and they feel
passionately to to decide on a career as
an officer in the us military
uh takes a certain level of patriotism
and takes a certain level of devotion
they're not going to get rich doing it
and
and they're not going to live a nice
quiet life because they're going to be
moving around and they're going to be
told where to move and when so it takes
a level of devotion that most of us
don't have to our uh careers or jobs and
and because of that i respect them a lot
but i think part of the reason they like
someone like like like george is because
he is a straightforward honest and and
very good reporter do you ever feel
you're being used when you're writing
stories oh i mean
the trick to being a good journalist is
to figure out when you're being used how
you can avoid it but to but to use these
motivations of your sources to get as
much information as you can this is what
the book looks like it's called
divorcing the dictator and our guest is
fred kemp who writes for the wall street
journal soon to go to berlin and the
berlin bureau there and unfortunately
we're running out of time and i've got a
lot to ask you about
is writing a book tough
it's it's the hardest and the most
enjoyable thing i've ever done hardest
because you just have to dig so much
harder than you do in daily reporting
most enjoyable because it's so rewarding
at the end that you really got so much
of the story where did you write it
i wrote it uh i wrote part of it in
panama and then
i wrote the bulk of it sitting in my uh
in my home on capitol hill is it a hard
is there a certain time of day that you
you write better than others yes i i
write best from about six in the morning
to ten in the morning and i write
and and from about seven until 11 at
night 7 p.m till 11 at night where'd you
get your first interest
in writing for a living
oh i think that uh i i think i i already
had it in junior high school in high
school i i just so much enjoyed
writing about things that i saw
and and reading authors that i enjoyed
and did you grow up i grew up in salt
lake city utah as a matter of fact i
mentioned that to noriega when i first
met him he mentioned it he asked me said
where are you originally from and i said
utah and he said oh yes the mormons they
have many intelligence agents where'd
you go to school uh i went to the
university of utah undergraduate and
then to
the graduate school of journalism at
columbia where i was also a member of
the international fellows program the
school of international affairs and you
wrote some for newsweek
yes i wrote for two years for newsweek
out of the bond bureau covering germany
and eastern europe you think ken adelman
in the acknowledgements how come well
ken adelman i think is a very savvy uh
political analyst
and
and
his institute the institute for
contemporary studies uh made available
to me in office to work out of in the uh
in the beginning months of the book and
the secretary to use to help me with uh
phone calls etc
we haven't got much time to talk about
this george bush uh this chapter we just
talked about chapter 17 goes into
chapter 18 the missed opportunity what
was that
the missed opportunity i think were the
negotiations of may of 1988.
reagan was making a deal to trade the
trade the uh noriega's resignation for
the dropping of the indictments reagan
thought it was a good deal and it was
almost completely done and then george
bush chose to oppose reagan on this deal
the first time that george bush stood
out publicly against ronald reagan on a
major foreign policy question
and
and i think the book goes into some
detail to outline how that decision was
made how the pressure of the campaign
the presidential campaign pushed bush
into opposition to ronald reagan and how
ultimately these pressures from bush
campaign and also from other politicians
closed the space on this deal and forced
the u.s to give noriega an ultimatum
24-hour ultimatum to either sign the
deal or everything would be off the
table
and so i guess uh you know we can't go
into all that detail now but i think my
the bottom line is that these
negotiations were cut off before one
really knew whether noriega was going to
go through with it or not
noriega was begging to sign the
documents
deposit them with the papal nuncio he
only wanted a little time to clear it up
with his military officers
and to get the backing domestically one
doesn't know whether he would have ever
been able to do that one doesn't know
whether he would have pulled the rug out
from under the end but we will never
know because we pulled the rug out from
the under the negotiations and it was
more for domestic policy considerations
the interests of the bush for president
campaign than it was because of national
security consideration what do you say
to the conspiracy theorists about the
george bush noriega connection and the
difficulties that might come out of a
trial
uh as as for george bush himself i was
unable to find any smoking gun and i
very much doubt that it exists
uh george bush went after noriega in two
methodical and forceful a manner to
think that
noriega has a lot on george bush that
being said i think ronald
that i think that noriega worked long
enough with the cia and other
intelligence agencies of the u.s
government to have a great deal of
information that could be embarrassing
to the u.s
i don't know whether that information
needs to come out for the trial because
it may not pertain to the charges
against him is it true that we paid
general noriega when he was working
as an intelligence
contact for us 200 000 a year uh what i
was able to ascertain was that in the
1970s he was paid up to a hundred ten
thousand dollars a year but it was not
paid to him personally it was paid to
the g2 his intelligence service
to quote unquote defray the cost of a
liaison relationship but noriega
obviously had control over the money in
the 1980s then
he was paid
starting at 185 000 a year and i
understand that it went up and this
isn't payment just from one intelligence
organization but from what chances do
you give panama for surviving under a
new government as a democracy i think
the real trick is
whether this leadership which is a white
sort of oligarchic leadership whether
this leadership will be clever enough to
reach out to the poorer sectors of
panama and help lift their living
standards and to be popular one of the
big mistakes i think this leadership has
made thus far is trying to completely do
away with all memory of the dictator
omar torrios they may have disagreed
with him but he was very popular with
the people
and i think that that shows uh not the
best political judgment
about out of time have you enjoyed the
book tour part of this thing and do you
find the americans are interested in
this subject i find americans are
fascinated with this subject the nuncio
said to me the real lesson the papal
nuncio when i interviewed him in the end
i said what's the moral of this story
and he said the moral is that your
institutions aren't as good as your
people and when the people found out
what noriega was
they wouldn't any longer allow their
politicians to maintain the relationship
they were maintaining and i think when
you go around the country you see that
the people are shocked with the sort of
relationship we had with this man with
the details of how long it had gone on
and almost a little bit embarrassed that
they didn't know about it earlier
anybody upset with what you wrote about
them in the book that you've heard from
uh so far so good i don't think i think
there are people who aren't happy and
they've told me that but there hasn't
been anybody who's called me and said
that they think that i've been unfair
our guest for the last hour has been
fred kemp and the book is called
divorcing the dictator
put out by putnam costs 24.95
thank you for joining us thank you very
much
[Music]
join us next week for book notes when
our guest will be david halevy co-author
of inside the plo a look at yasser
arafat the plo and their role in middle
east politics that's sunday march 18th
at 8 pm eastern time here on c-span
[Music]
as a service to schools c-span airs
short subject a 10-minute program each
tuesday beginning at 1 am eastern time
short subjects are educated